توفي باول هذا الصباح بسبب
مضاعفات مرض كوفيد 19 وتقول عائلته
إنه تم تطعيمه بالكامل ، لكننا علمنا أيضًا أن
باول كان يكافح
الورم النقوي المتعدد وهو سرطان الدم الذي يثبط
الاستجابة المناعية للجسم.
كان باول يبلغ من العمر 84 عامًا ،
غلوريا بورغر من CNN وإليزابيث كوهين انضموا
إلينا الآن إليزابيث قيل لنا إنك تعلم أنه
مصاب بسرطان الدم هذا
على الرغم من أنه كان قادرًا على الحصول على
اللقاح الذي لم يحميه
بنفس المستوى الذي يفعله العديد من الأشخاص الآخرين.
قام بتطعيم الغالبية
العظمى منا بشكل كامل الذين
حصلوا على تلك اللقاحات ، فقد أصيب أيضًا بمرض باركنسون
وقيل لنا إنه كان من المقرر أن يحصل على
جرعة معززة
في الأسبوع المقبل ولكن لأنه كان
مريضًا جدًا لدرجة أنه لم يكن قادرًا على
الحصول عليه  تلك الطبقة الإضافية من الحماية ،
فما الذي يمكن أن تخبرنا به أكثر عن
كل ذلك وكيف أثر
ذلك على هذه المعركة مع
kovid right anna حتى النخاع المتعدد
بالإضافة إلى مرض باركنسون الذي يعاني منه ، جعله أكثر
عرضة لمضاعفات الطمع 19.
الورم النقوي المتعدد كما قلت هو سرطان الدم ،
فهو يؤثر على نخاع العظام ،
مما يترك المرضى
في الحقيقة معرضين للخطر بطريقة
يصعب حقًا عكسها ومتى.
الأشخاص ضعاف المناعة - حتى
التطعيم المزدوج مع شركة فايزر
لا نعرفه ، لكن هذه اللقاحات ربما
لم تنجح بشكل جيد حتى لو
حصل على جرعة معززة ، فربما لم
تنجح بشكل جيد ونحن نعلم أن
الأشخاص الذين يعانون من ضعف المناعة في بعض الأحيان
لا تستخدم اللقاحات فقط  لن تعمل ثم
يمكن أن يؤثر مرض باركنسون جيدًا على
عضلات الجهاز التنفسي ، وبالتالي عندما
تواجه مشكلة في استخدام هذه العضلات ،
فربما يكون هناك صعوبة في التنفس ، وقد يؤدي
ذلك أيضًا إلى صعوبة في السعال ، مما
قد يجعل الأمور
أكثر تعقيدًا.  لذلك من
المحتمل أن كلا هذين العاملين قد ساهم